drei tote bei lkw unfall auf
bundesstraße laut polizei fuhr ein
autofahrer mit seinem pkw auf der
bundesstraße b 210 eine ortsumgehung der
kleinstadt jäger im landkreis friesland
und wollte einen lkw überholen der pkw
geriet dabei über eine doppelt
durchgezogene linie in den gegenverkehr
der fahrer des autos bemerkt sein fehler
versucht ihn mit einem ausweichmanöver
zu beheben zu spät ein entgegen
kommender laster kann nicht reagieren
prallt frontal in den lkw der überholt
werden sollte der pkw kräften beide
laster nach jetzigem kenntnisstand sind
leider drei tote zu beklagen
weiterhin ein schwerstverletzter und
eine schwerverletzte person diese beiden
personen sind mittlerweile im
krankenhaus
rettungskräfte und notfallseelsorger
sind mit einem großaufgebot vor ort die
aufräumarbeiten werden noch stunden
andauern
die polizei hat die ermittlungen zum
genauen unfallhergang aufgenommen